how do you rotate an object in three
dimensions so you take an object like
that and you rotate it that would be
something that's useful you can imagine
in computer graphics that how are you
going to do this now one of the neatest
ways of doing this mathematically uses a
new type of number beyond the regular
numbers you know so there's beyond the
real numbers as we call them there even
beyond the complex numbers if you've
heard complex numbers before it's even
beyond that they're called
quarter nians they're fantastic to
imagine I want to move along in one
dimension co-living somewhere here and
if I said move plus five plus five means
you move 5 units to the right along this
line so I'd end up over here if I said
instead move minus 3 you might
understand that means move three units
but that time move three units to the
left so that's how you move in one
dimension that's fairly easy isn't it
all right let's talk about moving around
in two dimensions and let's say I want
to end up at a point over here what that
might be three units this way let's call
that a three and then I move 4 units up
like that one way you could write that
as a set of instructions is to write it
as 3 plus 4i some of you may know what's
coming here some of you may have seen
this I before but for now let's just say
I means turn 90 degrees and go up and
down right for now that's what it means
all right so that's one way I could
travel to that point alternatively I
could look at it this way I could try
travel three across and four up or I
could rotate myself to this angle here
and move along this diagonal line here
and that would be 3 plus 4i as well all
right you could use the same
instructions to make that point that's
how you travel in two dimensions I mean
if I wanted to then go further and
travel maybe a bit more further on so
this they say I wanted to go
maybe one more across and two up like
that what I could do then by adding a
further one plus 2i I end up at this
point and I can say that this point is
the combined result which means a VAX
what three across and then a further one
four across and six up or if you like
it's the combined result of going from
here up to here so we can add these
numbers together and we should think of
them as numbers right you can add them
together and you can move around in two
dimensions so this time let's rotate
this line let's think what my combined
result here well I got this four plus
six I let's rotate this 90 degrees if I
rotate it 90 degrees I think it's going
to end up something like that and you
will end up here you will end up on a
point here so this is gonna be a 90
degree rotation this point is actually
at minus 6 plus 4i and that's where I
end up if I rotate these look similar to
each other why do they look similar how
can I get from this number to this
number what I've done actually is I've
multiplied instead of adding the numbers
together actually multiply this time by
the number we call it a number the
number I so there is a special rule with
this the special rule is I times itself
I times I is equal to minus one just to
show you what I did I took where I was 4
plus 6 I I multiplied it by I and what
did I get I got 4 I plus 6
well let's create I squared Oh what is
that that's 4 I minus 6 yeah or in other
words where I ended up here minus 6 plus
4 I so multiplying by that number I
means you rotate 90 degrees if you do it
twice you get minus 1 which does make
sense so if you rotate 90 degrees and
then rotate 90 degrees again you're 108
degrees now you're facing the opposite
direction so you're going negative
directions it does make sense and it
turns out that if you multiply these
numbers together you get rotations when
you multiply the two numbers together
you add their angles together so if I
want to rotate 45 degrees our depth my
triangle for 45 degrees 1 over root 2
there 1 over root 2 here
that's nice nice and that's a 1 now that
is a 45 degree angle written as a number
that is 1 over root 2 plus 1 over root 2
lots of I guess are gone that distance
across and in that distance up if I
multiply by that number
I would rotate by 45 degrees so adding
them together makes you travel around in
two dimensions multiplying them together
makes you rotate in two dimensions now
if you're ahead of me and if you've seen
this sort of thing before
you may recognize these as complex
numbers which by the way it's a terrible
name complex numbers which make sense I
like difficult numbers which I don't
think it's the intention I think the
idea is they are compound numbers there
are actually two dimensional numbers
that's a way of thinking of complex
numbers real numbers are one-dimensional
numbers complex numbers are
two-dimensional numbers and you can use
them to travel in 2d and rotate in 2d so
the question is how do we rotate in 3d
we must need three dimensional numbers
right so we must have to introduce an
eye and a J as well so we have three
dimension numbers and that's what people
thought it turns out we don't need three
dimensional numbers we need four
dimensional numbers to rotate in three
dimensions bizarrely you need a
four-dimensional number let me show you
how this works so that's that right so
there was an Irish mathematician called
William Hamilton and he was thinking
about this problem and he couldn't solve
it so it doesn't work in three
dimensions I can't get it to work and
the story goes that he was having a walk
with his wife along the canal in Dublin
and as suddenly inspiration struck and I
realized I don't need three dimensions I
need four dimensional numbers I need I J
and K so flushed with the
he immediately walked over to a nearby
bridge over the canal and he carved in
the rules that he needed to make this
work these are the rules that he carved
into that bridge I squared is equal to
the J squared which is equal to the K
squared which is equal to I times J
times K which is equal to minus one it's
very similar to the complex number idea
complex numbers I squared equals minus 1
that's what we needed for that it's very
similar but no we need I J and K he
carved this into the canal bridge which
unfortunately Kofi t what a water vandal
unfortunately it's not there anymore but
now there is a plaque celebrating the
rules of his discovery of quarter nians
the rules are there and every year
mathematicians around Dublin have a
pilgrimage to the spot where he had this
idea for quaternions for the first time
so by multiplying these four dimensional
numbers you can now rotate like like the
2d version you can rotate things in
three dimensions and this is how things
are done using computer graphics not
only that is how things are worked out
for the rotation or the orientation of a
space shuttle going up or it's how they
work out the orientation or the rotation
of your smartphone so they say I want to
rotate an object in three dimensions one
of those I pick a line like this pen
here i stamp the object with this pen
and then I can rotate around this pen
here so I might stab it this way and
then I can rotate the object like that
or I might stab this way so it rotates
the object this way or this way and so
we can rotate like that so how do we
write this so I take a line like that
and then I want to rotate around that
line let's do an angle of theta like
that let's call it V this line recording
V so it's a three-dimensional thing it
has three coordinates
let's call it V 1 and V 2 V 3 we're
going to let's take a point that's
getting rotated around let's call out a
P and that's sort of XY and Z for that
point in three dimensions this is how
things work but now we're going to
rotate it using a quarter nyan what does
a quaternion look like it looks like
this a quarter nyan let's call it h
would be something like a plus bi + c j+
d k and actually for this i do need
another little thing something called
hate star and hate star is a minus bi
minus CJ minus D K right if I want to
rotate by an angle R theta a B and C are
defined as a it's going to be equal to
COS of theta over 2 B is going to be
rewritten as v1 that's coming from my
vector here that my stabbing pen sine of
theta over to the C is v2 lots of sine
theta over 2 and the D need to the v3
lots of sine theta over T so it turns
out we need four components for our
number that we're going to use we need
four components to have the freedom to
do the stabbing and then the rotating
around that vector and how do you work
out the rotation then finally if P which
is the point I'm rotating you like P as
a quarter nyan it's coordinates are x
y&z it's actually X lots of I plus y
lots of J plus Z lots of K and finally
the rotation is H P H star right that's
the maths of it right that's the main
maths but we need four components to a
number to have the freedom to be able to
rotate around a vector and then move the
angle around it so the complex numbers
contain the real numbers as well and it
turns out the quarter nians contain the
complex numbers and in
turn they contain the real numbers and
when you don't need the J in the K now
you've got a complex number and if you
don't need the AI you've got a real
number so you might be thinking what's
next is that our next step up and there
is the next step up is octoly ins eight
dimensional numbers octo nians which
have their own set of rules as well very
similar but a very similar idea but
every time we go a step further we get a
bit more abstract this neelu's a bit of
structure and there's a property that
you lose each time you do it so the more
you do this the less useful they become
octo October
they're not as useful as quarter nians
are and there is then a step above that
the sixteen dimensional numbers the said
any ins but again you lose another
property when you go further and each
time you do they get perhaps less useful
so what are these properties that you're
losing each time you go further up
unfortunately what you lose is when you
go from the complex numbers to the
quarter nians the property you lose is
this